yeah I went to welcome to this video
place newburgh white and he plays the
Kings Indian you really so we will see
what happens maybe does something else
different move on a meeting night a six
know what this one then Queenie aid is
what he tried in an earlier game but
that other similarly plate plate thing I
know I can do this immediately I'm send
him back okay so it should be three I
guess and now i wonder if i should go h3
and then back and it's probably not bad
from another bad choice but you can can
play this in different ways so it feels
a bit strange to do but ok let's do it
he has lost much more time anyway
reaching that usually means that why it
is in good shape so on g4 I guess night
besides or something this is never okay
for black really never but it's less to
repeat it and still have to refute it so
let's see what happens here I can take
on c5 and 394 immediately OMG one ok
I'll start the group g1
there's no direct way answer to punish
them for this I guess
now I actually overestimated that
initially that is not so bad for black
in this precise position f5 often just
does not work at the g4 but this is not
one of those situations it is playable
it is playing or what is day huh both
captures make some sense
yeah my development is not good this is
the thing and in fact that one more
expert MP everything would be cool yeah
he might take age three I mean it's very
cheeky to do but he might take it he
didn't so what to do here Queen f3 is
also coming into consideration here
right doesn't look too bad
why can I not take on that five and to
just be a much better let's see we'll
see why or maybe not so keen to and
cheer for next that's really really
awful for like this ending it was pretty
relaxed and going into this surprisingly
it's got basically all pawns on dark
squares which means any ending night
against bishop is probably pretty much
done sprint and have easy ways to
improve and be three and so on we'll see
ya week 33 and I mature trade one or
let's say I don't mind to trade one look
here's the thing okay if I take now you
will take with the pawn something I
don't need to allow in this particular
way
okay there is no nothing possible here
like on the edge filer so no more not
possible so how to do a to f3 trading
one pair of books would be nice getting
look h4 doesn't really do anything at
all maybe I have to play for d6 and then
enter like that it's probably the right
way to do it it costs a bit of time
unfortunately this move
and what he treats this I'm so if you
take on g4 that would be fully fantastic
I could have taken myself also it this
is Sarah this is looking good
so what's going on here do I have a
tactic no I can take care right let the
web stuff
[Music]
I can check night there on just group
here but many many good things available
can also take their you have six or get
six immediately a new page five maybe
time money actually admiring this
position a bit too much I should click
liquor
check take a second pause
[Music]
okay okay absolutely i wanted to play
with this heaven but it's pretty lost
anyway
welcome let the clock run down if he
likes nothing much to do about it and I
really really am unsure about the
position right after the opening because
at five and I generally don't believe in
this move but it is so difficult to do
difficult to play yeah okay whatever so
I don't think this is particularly great
but then I'm not sure about this this h3
what I played that probably not the best
we'll see how long is that what happens
here don't don't tell me I have a glass
for sex only time okay okay that would
have been pretty awful to lose on all
time on a disconnection for me to do
that okay so let's switch that on and
have a look so night h4 so that pretty
much yeah refutes this this stuff night
h5 create it's just the question how to
do it you don't have to play this age 32
or what I did certainly we can also add
the engine gives capsules because black
has just lost time but I like the idea
to get this ideal setup going and then F
smile
it usually that doesn't do work in such
a situation right in this film it is
tough to do tough to play our queen see
to make scratch a lot of sense yes
prepare long capsules and asking how
it's going to get it back one in five it
looks like a good move and if it goes
reform night be high for 94 moon gem or
just this I think it probably must be
complete hell and to play such a
position with black against the computer
just a pure pure calculation slugfest
against you ok so I went for the control
of each wallet share as the engine gears
and it isn't that isn't so great but
what you shouldn't do is for sure now
play this one it is just a grave
positional error to get a position that
is I think maybe is typically losing
with the night only for ya the should
Bishop d7 is certainly better we will
check here I just get this fantastic
knight on e4 and I have an easy game
Luke g41 and basically any ending with
the night against bishop is almost
winning so um thank you think I did a
decent job here like that just if it's
lost after after that transformation I
think I probably played then being
played in the best possible way of it it
was enough to check them keep a winning
advantage you wanted to play just I
guess and it
points for for basically nothing I think
in the opening I should probably avoid
this age three moves that that didn't
look too convincing con.close expand
expection inspection thanks for watching